president drum fighting back after House
Democrats launched an expansive new
investigation House Judiciary Chairman
Jerry Nadler requesting documents from
81 people and organizations associated
with the president Nadler defending the
move
we're simply exercising oversight
jurisdiction you've had two years of
sustained attacks by an administration
of NATO that we haven't seen probably in
a century or more against the Free Press
against the courts against the law
enforcement administration's against
freedom of speech we have to make sure
that this is not a dictatorship and that
the rule of law is respected president
Trump blasting the new probe I guess we
got 81 letters there was no collusion
that was a hoax there was no anything
and they want to do that instead of
getting legislation passed it's a
disgrace it's a disgrace to our country
I'm not surprised that it's happening
basically they've started the campaign
so that campaign begins but they just
haven't gotten used to the fact that we
want a lot of states that haven't been
won by Republicans in a long time so
instead of doing infrastructure instead
of doing health care instead of doing so
many things that they should be doing
they want to play games
infrastructure week is gonna be awesome
Jesse when they get around to it so
calls for impeachment are hard to
control when the base wants what it
wants
and it's just they're gonna keep asking
for it and these chairmen even if they
want to tap the brakes they're being
pushed into it it's a runaway train and
the media is is fueling the fire as well
these numbers from the president that
just came out are pretty spectacular as
in the NBC polls approval ratings at 46%
Rasmussen is at 48 Harvard and Harris
have him at 45 blacks he's in the mid
20s mid 20s and then the base the
Republicans have him at 93
sorry haters so despite all of the stuff
they've thrown at this guy
you know the spies the lies the probes
the 25th amendment all this stuff his
numbers are at or near record high so
the buzz from the Muller report is
theirs
not gonna be all this collusion that
they're gonna report so the Democrats
are getting nervous and they're
scrambling for new crimes and it doesn't
look like they've found any in the house
report and the center report and the
counter-intel probe and the sentencing
memos from Muller indicated that they
don't really have anything there so the
bottom line is this there is nothing
that the middle class can look and see
what the Democrats are doing and say
this affects my life this is what I want
I want to see Trump's taxes I want these
investigations I want Don jr. up on the
hill
it doesn't deliver and the pullings
never shown it's deliver if I were the
president I would cooperate but I would
I would call privilege on a lot of this
stuff the same way Barack Obama did yep
and also just speaking of that Jedidiah
Politico reporting that the Democrats do
plan to demand president Trump's tax
returns in about two weeks which I guess
our that gets us closer to tax day yeah
maybe that's what they're looking for I
mean I've said we're only 81 entities
they're getting lazy I mean I was hoping
for at least a hundred 150 it's
basically it's ridiculous it's it's this
is so desperate now that even people who
originally were on board saying look if
there was collusion with Russia let's
investigate it let's figure it out all
the rational people have left the room
and now everyone that's left is looking
at this and saying okay these are people
who are dissatisfied with the election
results they don't have an agenda of
their own that's appealing to people
what are you going to go out to most of
the country and talk the way AOC does
socialism a green new deal
none of this stuff makes practical sense
to the average person the average person
in the United States is not a socialist
they see that it sounds extreme
Democrats need to learn though you're
not gonna win an election by going after
the other guy and being constantly
negative about him you have to bring
something positive to the table yourself
so they either need to be proud of this
very very extreme agenda that includes
late term abortion let them talk about
infanticide and getting rid of all the
electric cars in ten years either be
proud of that put that front and center
and make that do what you got to do and
create some optimism there or leave the
room because you you are giving Trump a
victory right now by doing this and the
poll numbers show that one can the
Democrats do that will I continue to go
after President Trump but also maybe
meet him
on infrastructure bill or something like
that like is there a way for them to
actually do both with the base that
really wants them to just fight no I
think the base wants them to legislate
as well as investigate so I don't think
there's any problem there I think they
can do two things at one time I must say
I have a very different view when I look
at the poll numbers 45 46 % that's his
high Jessie it's not high for most
presidents I understand but that's still
I think that's true but it remember
Obama was at a low point this guy's at
his high point but here's the thing if
you look at those numbers 64 percent of
Americans right now think that the
president should release his tax returns
that's two-thirds of the American people
how about this half of the respondents
this Quinnipiac poll came out today
think that they believe guess this this
is so unbelievable to me they believe
Cohen more than they believe Trump 64
percent think that Trump committed
crimes before he was president of the
United States so Republicans have a
strong affinity for the Constitution as
it was written and the Constitution is
very clear Congress is an equal branch
of government with oversight
responsibilities and they need to gather
facts and the course of exercising
oversight before they come to any kind
of decision about impeachment and the
like but Republicans are acting like oh
it's impeachment right now you can honor
that me let me get Gregg in face I'm
sorry we've talked about how Democrats
maybe it would be helpful for President
Trump to have someone to fight against
all right so now he has somebody to push
back against and now the Democrats are
kind of providing him that which I think
makes him look more like a statesman
well imagine that you're like a surgeon
or an air traffic controller right doing
your job and outside the window is like
a birthday clown juggling chainsaws
that's the Democrats their role right
now simply is to distract a man from
doing his job the problem is he's
America's air traffic controller he's
America's surgeon so a lot of people
kind of don't like this distraction
let's say you have a normal job I was
thinking about this today let's say you
have a normal job you're an electrician
or an intern
agent and all of a sudden your boss
comes in and says hey you know what I'd
like you to devote more time into
investigating that electrician across
the street or devote more time to
investigating that insurance agent
across the street and dirt on that as if
yes as if you have time right you have
time to do this so what I'm learning is
these politicians have a lot of time to
do this sort of thing in the sense they
are creating an argument for their own
uselessness that they're able to do
unending investigations at best being a
congressman is a part-time job it's a
seasonal occupation like being a
department store Santa or an NFL ref and
what we have done by allowing them to
have a full-time job is we're allowing
them to investigate instead of legislate
I've I've learned everything and it's
left or right or center this should not
be a full-time job it and and I think
that you have to be better than the
people who upset you eight years ago
there were people like this about Obama
right you know there are people that
were convinced Obama was going to be a
dictator right he was going to seize
power you're just doing what they're
doing
you're just dude you are now a mirror of
the people you despise you should step
out of this and look down and see that
you're no better than they are Jesse
I'll give you the last word the
Democrats do say that Republicans went
way overboard investigating Obama and
all they could point to all sorts of
hearings and document requests and
trying to gum up the works and being the
clown outside the airplane how long
eight investigations where Americans
died and Americans died in fast and
furious what's a funny one well because
probably it's funny that they it's funny
that they die they'll see you said it's
totally legitimate when Republicans do
it but illegitimate when there's a dead
American I want my Congress to
investigate and hey vikander Democrat if
he's dead
youth the only things dead is the
Democrats electoral chances in 2020 and
that's what this is all about can I
speak
go ahead I think that you are arguing
that this president should be immune
from accountability no I'm okay
arguing and more sunlight on this guy
than any other prison I can even
remember guess are you arguing then that
if there's a conflict of interest if he
has in fact some kind of ties with
Russia during the bookends I'm willing
to look at the model court one I don't
know it's not going to deliver the goods
and all these others I think you're
hopeful but I'm saying Congress has
legitimate responsibility why are you so
upset when Democrats exercise that
responsibility but not upset when
Republicans went on for five years about
they don't look upset one I'm actually
happy